les paparazzi et paparazzi suivent et
nos mémoires et habitant depuis la
plainte c'est bien sûr surtout depuis
qu'il sait qu'il a déménagé on sait
qu'il allait s'installer dans lui
tiennent dans un petit appartement pour
rester un petit peu reclus loin des
journalistes et surtout de de tout ce
battage autour de lui l'article de paris
match à mon avis va lui faire va pas lui
faire le plus grand bien loin de là
parce que là on va dire ce qui ce qui se
pose qui se trouvent dans cet article
inscrire ma miss kier à côté bah en fait
ce qui se trouve dans cet article c'est
tous les détails donc là l'étau se
resserre parce que sincèrement ce qu'on
comprend en lisant en lisant cet article
c'est tout ce qu'on se dit nous les
journalistes les médias c'est des choses
qui circulent un petit peu on en parle
entre nous mais ce n'était jamais sorti
à ce point c'est à dire les détails de
la soirée passée avec avec la plaignante
est sortie publique oui mais pas ce
point là là là là cette soirée 1 en
intégralité avec les blessures le
constat du médecin le constat des
policiers et puis surtout surtout
la génèse un petit peu de la plainte de
cette jeune femme alors wagram
validation tout ce qui s'est passé parce
que paris match nous raconte tout alors
c'est paris match
alors une jeune parisienne donc de 21
ans employée d'une plateforme numérique
qui n'est pas sa compagne officielle
l'accuse de viol avec violences donc
samedi 30 octobre 20h un rabbit en
reçoit vert peu avant 20 heures une
jeune femme dans son appartement
parisien du viiie arrondissement
20h30 ils ont alors une première
relation sexuelle consentie un rapport
protéger et agréable selon la peña la
plaignante 21h30 les 2 din sur la table
basse ils regardent la télévision les 20
ans de la star academy harry souhaite
faire l'amour avec la jeune femme pour
la deuxième fois et c'est là que tout
aurait basculé durant la seconde
relation il aurait été très violent et
aurait pratiqué une pénétration anale
non consenti alors que la jeune femme
aurait plusieurs fois dit non elle
connaît alors selon paris match une
expérience traumatisante une pénétration
anale non désirées un rapport vaginal
très brusque des claques une
strangulation et ses cris des cris
répétés suivi d'une douleur aiguë
affreuse à trois reprises à lui aurait
demandé d'arrêter en vain harry prétexte
une erreur puis une fois son affaire
terminée lui demande de l'aider à
changer et à laver les draps souillés d'
éléments constituant des preuves de ce
compte de ce que son accusatrice avancé
pris une très longue douche voilà ce
qu'elle dit à paris match elle raconte
la scène à son ami par sms le magazine
dévoile le contenu il s'est passé un
truc pas cool pendant l'acte je lui ai
demandé d'arrêter il a continué je me
sens mal samedi 30 octobre 22h30 harry
se rend une fête la jeune femme rejoint
ses amis qui lui dit qu'elle doit porter
plainte quand tu dis nous c'est non
l'important c'est ton corps pour
consentement c'est ce que raconte un
paris match et ensuite qu'à me décide
d'aller chez lui alors il disait je sais
pas quoi ils appellent donc paris match
il dit voilà c'est non ils ont changé le
prénom du fils camille elle est
auscultée par un médecin elle souffre de
plusieurs hématomes sur la cuisse de
pelé vaginales et anales vivent
également d'un trauma au coccyx deux
jours d'incapacité temporaire totale
somatiques réévalué à dix jours lui
seront prescrits voilà il ya ensuite
voilà donc c'est qu'ils répondent tout
petit la faire c'est pour ça que je
parle des détails qui sont révélées ces
restes point la wii pour la première
fois et que l'étau se resserre vraiment
autour d'harry habitants parce que là il
ya tout et la journaliste moi je les ai
eus au téléphone emilie blachère avant
l'émission celle qui a réalisé cet
accord cadre il a eu un mois et demi
presque deux mois pour bosser uniquement
sur ceux sur ce dossier là elle elle
signe de a à z tout ce qui est écrit
c'est pour ça qu'elle emploie quasiment
pas le conditionnel c'est quand même
dans un cas comme celui-là assez violent
parce que c'est des faits extrêmement
graves et elle d'ailleurs ce qui la
surprend et ce qui surprend aussi
beaucoup beaucoup d'observateurs c'est
le fait qu'ils soient en liberté qu'ils
soient pas en détention provisoire
certains s'interrogent sur le fait qu'
est-ce que c'est parce qu'il s'appelle
ary abittan qu'il était encore en
liberté aujourd'hui parce que les faits
sont quand même très grave on rappelle
qu'il était à punta cana ya pas très
longtemps donc son équipe l'équipe 2
qu'est ce qu'on a fait au bon dieu
commence et c'est que c'est que le juge
a jugé qu'il n'était pas dangereux pour
les eaux tout à fait mais il ya des cas
similaires sur un point un plan
juridique ou les bleuets match très
enlevé les enfants
ça existe même très souvent donc on peut
juste construit que c'est qu'un parc 1
l'a tué c'est au cas par cas voilà et
moi sur ce que je sais il aurait vu la
juge d'instruction courant janvier n'a
pas été confirmée mais en tout cas c'est
ce qui se dit lui ne sait absolument pas
quand est-ce qui sera jugée parce que
les enquêteurs pour l'instant essaye et
c'est raconter aussi dans l'article
c'est à dire de retrouver ses ex des
anciennes amies petite amie alors
justement d autres témoignages pour
corroborer un peu tout ce qui s'est dit
ou ce qui est écrit là alors justement
ils disent qu'ils dédient dans paris
match arrêt habitants ne se contente pas
de nier les firent présent ils accusent
jure qu'il n'a fait que répondre
désir et fantasmes de sa partenaire une
jeune fille de 23 ans leurs 21 ans 23
ans et part en contre et deux mois plus
tôt et dans ce numéro de paris match
c'est vrai que contre énormément de
témoignages alors il ya plein de gens
qui lisent aussi oui mais si on veut
ôter témoignages à charge c'est vrai que
c'est quand on va poser des questions
c'est sûr qu'à des gens qui vous aiment
bien il ya des gens qui vous à moins
donc forcément pour avoir des
témoignages d'enfants alors elle dénonce
la jeune fille dans paris match un
comportement agressif et parle de double
personnalité il a besoin de
reconnaissance et d'amour monstrueux une
actrice qui a joué avec art habitants
dans une fiction sur france 2 parle d'un
dragueur lourd dos mal polis mais pas
méchant mais d'autres vont plus loin il
se permet des regards impudique des
gestes inappropriés inconfortable voire
des propos déplacés ils s'attaquent aux
débutants de vulnérable jamais au
premier rôle quand on ose s'opposer à
ses avances il devient grossier il
brille et quand on s'en offusque on nous
répond que c'est lui la star
et
selon paris match dans le huis clos
d'une chambre à coucher arrêt habitants
se révèle insistant maniaque et crus
ajoutent que le problème à hikari et
accary c'est qu'ils partent du principe
que tout est acquis lorsqu'on accepte de
venir prendre un café ou qu'on répond
poliment à son sourire une de ses
conquêtes ajoute il m'a embrassé sur la
bouche semble connaître ils m'embrassent
et sans délicatesse et me tripoter
grossièrement le sexe je n'ai pas
compris ce qu'il se passait il a pris ma
seule présence comme un consentement
quand je les repousser son regard était
méchant j'ai essayé de discuter mais il
est allé plier son linge je me sentais
comme du bétail un peu sale conne je
suis parti il n'a pas eu un mot gentil
au contraire ils étaient dénigrant aucun
regret aucune excuse paris match évoque
également l'état mental de la turquie
serait bien entendu affectés aujourd'hui
mameria palombes à vous vous avez les
mêmes infos que paris-match closer
et mark hollis n êtes producteur vous
trouvez vous vous trouvez vous que
l'asse il ya un lien il ya un
acharnement sur un habitant déjà ce que
j'entends c'est que on a eu une première
relation avec une personne de 23 ans qui
est derrière
sa part envoyé quoi
ça part en vrille séquelles plus
d'accord et et il se passe plein de
choses on n'est pas d'accord pour faire
au moins est d'accord pour ça non mais
qui lui fait non mais oui mais ce que je
ne comprends pas c'est pourquoi n'est
pas parti de quoi
la mena
moi ce que je vois en fait pour et non
parce que elles étaient là étaient
ensemble ils jouent ce soir là oui mais
s'il avait oui c'est pas la même
relation qu'elle a voulu et qui avoue
n'avoir après que fab vous avez droit de
refuser
oui mais elle la refuse visiblement
selon ses propos elle a été forte
contrainte de la sphère contrainte bah
oui
ou en fait si vous voyez résumer ma
présence et que moi en fait dans cette
affaire-là
et je veux des preuves
alors
donné la donné à luis alonso jeune homme
et il
est génial et le boxer des cas c'est
enfin à l'armé blanche des hématomes c
est selon ce qui est très bien raconté
ce qui est intéressant pour répondre à
monsieur c'est que justement elle rentre
elles rentrent pas chez elle mais elle
va retrouver des amis après cette soirée
là donc justement on le traumatisme en
fait qu'elle vit à ce moment-là et
raconter je trouve si les réels
extrêmement bien parce qu'on comprend ce
qu'elle a vécu il ya ce sms qu'on a
retrouvé ici passer un truc pas cool
voilà exactement il ya ce sms il ya
apparemment des preuves qui sont donc
vraiment mises en avant dans ce papier
avec des preuves médicales des preuves
des preuves policière bon franchement
sincèrement c'est très compliqué c'est
des choses qu'on se disait nous entre
nous on va dire la vérité entre
journalistes gens de médias etc on
savait ce qui ce qui si on y est et là c
est chris avait déjà été créés dans le
public mais là dans paris - clavier tout
ça il s'agit on s'en parle eh oui c'est
des choses qui circulent avant que ça
sorte ça c'est d'abord des bruits et
puis progressivement ça devient des
preuves et on va pas si tu as la justice
mais c'est très facile après avec ce
genre d'article la présomption
d'innocence n'existe plus c'est un
monsieur c'est vrai que dans ce dossier
d'une présomption d'innocence total
d'arrêt à bierne entendez vous avez
raison mais dans ce dossier ce qui est
particulier par rapport à d'autres
affaires c'est qu'à une suite
chronologique très précise qui a été
établie minute par minute on l'a vu là
un bleu est révélée dans paris match
aussi par les enquêteurs et qu'il y a à
disposition des enquêteurs après des
expertises médicales et d'autres
expertises des éléments matériels c'est
ça c'est ça qui fait que les charges
sont l'autre c'est pour ça qu'il a été
mis en examen pour viol présumé innocent
mais ça veut dire que le juge avait
selon lui des éléments sérieux qui
nécessite mise en examen concordants
donc il n'y a pas rien dans le dossier
mais on n'en connaît pas l'issue bien
sûr bon moi je respecte bien évidemment
cette jeune personne que je ne connais
pas du tout maintenant il existe aussi
des gens qui sont sado maso
mais je veux dire non mais ça existe
aussi ça existe aussi je ne dis pas que
c'est le cas parce que moi je n'étais
pas présent et bien évidemment mais je
dis que
je veux dire c'est que ici il ya peu des
gens connus demain
on est tous des hommes 1 on drague
on a tous travaillé on a tous eu une
relation je veux dire mais et demain
matin la personne qui va te dépose et
complaintes combos mais c'est
consentement ou non consentement
messieurs ça dont il était friand quoi
on expulse en temps ou par mathieu
voiture est un peu près terre dans ces
histoires là c'est quand c'est parole
contre parole qotb bourdin contre une
fille qui va sûrement y azerot témoins
il n'y a rien il n'ya pas d'hématome y a
rien qu'on dégage bourdin moi perso je
trouve ça dégueulasse parce que là c'est
parole contre parole la canton revanche
un médecin est passé qui l'a constaté
tout ça est à moins que la fille soit
sado-maso je ne sais pas et qu'elle aime
se faire casser des côtes le coccyx
qu'avoir des hématomes et avait des
déchirures vaginale à moins qu'elle aime
ça et que les témoignages dans ces cas
là alors là effectivement oui il faut
que tout sorte dans la presse et il faut
qui mise en examen dans le cas d'un
habitant que tout sorte ça ne me choque
pas du tout ça ne me choque pas dans le
cas de bordeaux en revanche ça m'a
choqué alors juste un bidon parce qu'on
se connaît on apprécie dans ton boulot
t1 un professionnel est un hectare
évitant courage à toi de le défendre ce
soir alors j'essaye les hommes que nous
sommes les hommes de notre génération
c'est pour ça que je te parle moi oui on
peut plus permettre d'avoir ce type
d'argument pardon à me dire pourquoi
elle s'est pas enfui quand tu te fais
violer ou quand tu te fais agresser
sexuellement était une femme ou un homme
d'ailleurs ne peuvent attendre fuir nas
que telle en stress parce que tape nord
parce que l'on prenne à ce parce que
visiblement c'était art ce qui s'est
passé alors sado maso ou pas mais
entendre l'argument de dire à une femme
qui se fait violer tu aurais pu s'enfuir
banon ok je peux lire les vivants qui
m'agace aussi un petit peu pardon je me
faire insulter mais j'en ai marre aussi
un petit peu d'entendre les femmes qui
disent alors il m'a convoqué d'un 520 4
heures du mat pour parler boulot il m'a
convoqué
il habite à cinq heures pascal alors
voilà c'est pas se passer mais aussi
beaucoup de filles maintenant aussi
pardon arrêter de nous prendre ça s'est
vu sur la sphère bourdin tout à l'heure
mais
c'est là qu'ils ont dû dire qu il s est
battu lan maintenant c'est de faire des
idiotes il ya un moment où il faut
convenir de l'avenue geneslay 14 direct
pendant les bulu n'y va pas et alors
alors maladie m'a jamais répondu quand
bien même la mairie tu verras 4 heures
du matin ah oui première intention et
éventuellement des relations sexuelles
si au dernier moment où tu dis non m
même si tu là alors on est d'accord même
si toi tu sais pas pourquoi je suis
d'accord mais en revanche le toutes ces
actrices qui jouent le jeu et faire
mouche et parce qu'elle 4 heures du
matin pour leur parler d'un contrat tu
sais que quand il va là tu dis pardon on
en parlera demain midi dans sa chambre
et a pris sous les radios l'un n'empêche
pas l'autre en fait effectivement qu'il
ya des gens qui se mettent en danger
volontairement mécène même si on a eu un
rapport sexuel ça va même plus loin que
d'aller dans une chambre à quatre heures
du matin même si on a eu un premier
rapport sexuel on n'est pas forcé
d'accepter un deuxième ni un troisième
même si on a eu 50 on n'est jamais
obligé ce quand c'est non c'est non et
ça j'ai jamais eu et on apprécie que
fernand la faire vous regarde ce que tu
oublie c'est que c'est une jeune femme
qui était vraiment qui était stagiaire
et qu'ils étaient tous de jeunes
quittent enfin voilà ah oui mais c'est
parole contre parole n'y a pas de caméra
y'a rien pour l'instant on fait tomber
un homme pour l'instant pour quelle pour
deux personnes dans une piscine que
personne n'a vu sait tous que quand tu
auras plus de choses sur broadway sera
le premier à dire ok mais on n'y a rien
béatrice comment commence à voir comme
dit mathieu si voilà olala la jeune
fille il ya quand même on voit qu'il ya
eu des violences soient là mais couvrir
on a eu une relation sexuelle une
première fois on n'a pas envie d'en
avoir une deuxième citant comme on fait
ce qu'on fait pour savoir en faire dans
l'art après si c'est parole contre
parole comment ça se passe là c'est pas
parole contre parole il ya quand même
des preuves bien sûr dans les natures
oui c'est pour ça oui là tu es là dessus
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des trucs quand
même
avec mathieu que pour l'histoire de jean
jacques bourdin j'avais d'ailleurs été
très choquée sur l'attitude de valérie
pécresse j'avais j'ai été extrêmement
choqué je suis pas une fan de jean
jacques bourdin loin de là mais vraiment
j'ai trouvé ça
déplorable cette façon de le prendre sur
le vif devant un public caressa pour
angers
en quoi
embêter mais l'étau cancale et lui dire
la première femme qui est d'accord avec
moi là dessus je sais c'est vrai c'est
vrai béatrice vous vous avez déjà eu
c'est vrai que voilà est-ce que vous
avez déjà eu des des trucs des trucs
lourd genre des mecs qui vous disent de
voile à devenir non d'héroïne par
exemple je connais tous les cas de
figure j'en connais mes jeunes femmes
dont parle mathieu qui vont dans la
suite à cannes à 4 heures du matin pour
discuter contrat et j'ai aussi une
proposition d' harvey wine steen
d'aller à 2 heures du matin
ces erreurs comment il l'a fait quand
ils vous envoyez un sms il n'a non pas
du tout on était un événement à l'époque
c'était oman rai uno sur oman air et
non celle
de
vianne ferment on était un événement
donc avait beaucoup de monde et
heureusement qu'il y avait beaucoup de
monde autour et il me dit
en anglais est ce que tu veux à me
rejoindre au ritz à telle heure et je
dis non merci et puis j'ai essayé d'être
poli voilà mes de décliner en étant poli
non merci je suis fatigué je vais
rentrer il ya merci beaucoup et il me
dit et tu sais qui je suis et tu veux
continuer sa carrière d'actrice donc
voilà ça c'est voilà il y avait du monde
autour et heureusement parce que je vois
là sinon je ne sais pas et c'est par ce
sera fait ça incroyable ça oui
heureusement j'aimerais revenir sur la
variable sur ary abittan nature quelque
chose qui grèvent vraiment intéressant
dans ce papier c'est que la journaliste
dresse le portrait du personnage et il
ya deux choses moi qui m'ont qui m'ont
interpellé le 1er séquelles exhume une
déclaration qui l'avait fait lui même
c'est à dire qu'il avait dit sur le
plateau de c'est à vous en 2019 souffrir
d'une maladie psychologique qui lui en
gros ils avaient peur de faire des trucs
grave pour résumer vous donne
l'impulsion sas à poil avec seulement
une phobie d'impulsion donc ça c'est
quand même intéressant à la lumière de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui d'en parler
et par contre il ya aussi alors ça je
pense que ça se discute c'est à dire de
de conjuguer un petit peu tous ces
élèves tous les éléments de dragueur
lourd d'eau de f1 et pour appuyer les
accusations d'aujourd'hui je pense que
ces deux choses différentes donc voilà
ce que le temps intéressant d'en parler
sinon ceux ci on avait fait un portrait
des habitants au moment où il était
hyper sympa et tout ça peut-être qu'il y
aurait eu des filles à qui la drague et
qui aurait d'ailleurs il était super
sympa en rigolait il déconne f voilà moi
je trouve que c'est indique me dérange
un peu sur ce point actuel pour nos
remarques et l'accès vraiment
dégueulasse de ressortir le passé parce
que pardon alors ça veut dire oui c'est
demain franck dubosc avec une histoire
comme ça par libreville ne pas fonder un
projet emballant
des pas d'exemple
on le sentirait façon il a toujours joué
les gros dragueur lourd en heure il a
toujours c'est ça on peut pas ressortir
le passé comme ça dans les étoiles qui
sont ponctuels vrai que c'est un peu
gênant
bon on sait on s'est quand même tout le
monde est dans le spectacle ici et dans
le show business q mais là qui vont
bientôt sortir
les femmes rêvent de sortir avec une
dette non non beaucoup beaucoup
n'ont pas d'amis son peuple bien sans
regarder daniel elle commence à voir son
petit succès
mais moi j'assume même la raison à
l'époque de tout
genre de
permettre à raison le succès la lumière
l'argent ça si on va dire pardon et et
ritag 1 mais vous êtes dans ballard il a
raison alors
qu'on m'arrête pas d'autres
jamais eu envie quand même quand j'étais
plus jeune et fan de certaines stars
j'avais envie de coucher avec
vous n'avez jamais été je n'avais jamais
ressenti ces viandes et 150 et et vous
daniel quand vous étiez jeune n'avait
jamais eu envie de jean carmet
[Applaudissements]
matthews te dit c'est vrai
regardez benjamin là aussi la raison
monsieur vise à montrer encore une fois
c'est pas parce qu'on est sollicitée
qu'on doit mal se comporter a bien sûr
fait exactement avec les autres je veux
pas mais au moins pour leur bien sûr
harry et avec zine ce qui est dit dans
paris match vous le dit et on peut le
dire maintenant tout ce qui est des
crises a fait et je veux qu'on aurait
parlé ensemble ça fait un mois et demi
qu'on est au courant dans le moindre des
hommes furent annoncés ce qu'elles ont
fait rien donc fait pas du tout c'est
assez visiblement alors il en fait il ya
deux théories il ya un peu la théorie de
il s'est rien passé du tout acquis le
blanchit complètement et à cette théorie
là mais visiblement il ya une
perquisition dans l'appartement et des
preuves qui ont été récoltés dont il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'éléments à
charge il reste présumé innocent mais
dans ce cas d'arrêt en étant tous à
effectuer dans paris vous dire la vérité
tout le monde le savait tout le monde le
savait